one other clip i want to look at related
to
the supreme court leaker so we had a
more serious discussion a few minutes
ago in the context of what tulsi gabbard
said about the kind of equal likelihood
based on what we know right now that the
leaker might have been someone on the
left who supports abortion rights or
someone on the right who's against
abortion rights we just don't know one
way or the other
but now i want to play for you a clip
from newsmax
where uh the host grant stinkfield with
absolutely no evidence whatsoever
speculates that it might be
the not yet on the court
but confirmed justice katanji brown
jackson who leaked the draft now there's
no evidence of that she's also not on
the court and how she would have access
to the draft i don't know but here's
grant stinkfield's perspective
we're not telling them what they can do
to their bodies though we're telling
them what they can't do to a baby a
precious life and speaking of catanje
brown jackson you just saw there
i find it suspect that the first leak
coming out of the supreme court in
history
comes shortly after judge jackson is
confirmed
i want to know if her law clerks who i
am sure have already been hired possibly
even working at the high court already
before her swearing-in have access to
these draft decisions
she would be my first suspect when it
comes to the leak because catanje brown
by the way katanje they just can't get
it right jackson is a radical left-wing
activist more radical than any other
justice in the history of the supreme
court i think what he means is as
qualified as any other justice on the
supreme court so we don't know who it
was this is total speculation it might
have been someone on the left it might
have been someone on the right we know
why each side might have motivations to
leak this
but
katanji brown jackson is not on the
court
there is no evidence that i was able to
find
that her forthcoming clerks are already
at the supreme court with access to
documents there's just no evidence of
this whatsoever and understand i don't
know if this the hypothesis is going to
pick up steam
but the way that it'll work is
newsmax will float it without evidence
and then people on twitter will talk
about it
and then tucker will say there are many
people saying
it might have been katanji brown jackson
it's what he did with the vaccines
remember oh um it might uh there are
people saying tens of thousands of
people died from the coveted vaccines
i'm not saying that but there are people
saying that and then all of a sudden
it's on fox news at night and then the
next day fox news the hard news program
say uh tucker carlson last night said
that and that's how it gets into the
news cycle so we'll see what kind of
life this hypothesis about katanji brown
jackson being the leaker um uh gets i
hope that it's not much but there is
absolutely no evidence and it violates
uh a absolute and complete um uh
instinct
where she's not even working there
there's no reason to think her clerks
are there there's no reason to think
katanji brown jackson has anything to do
with this